[Musique]
merci Cédric Perin de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu du territoire de bellefor
membre du groupe les républicains et
tout nouveau président de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées on a évidemment
beaucoup de sujets à aborder avec vous
on va commencer par cette attaque à
haras une minute de silence ser respecté
à 14h en hommage à Dominique Bernard ce
professeur de français assassiné victime
du terrorisme islamiste Gabriel soir au
20h a été très ferme il ne tolérera
aucune contestation pendant ce temps
dommage vous redoutez des incidents
écoutez d'abord je voudrais avoir une
pensée pour les enseignants qui
reprennent des cours ce matin dans des
conditions parfois compliquées qui vont
devoir effectivement affronter une
journée un peu difficile ou comme la
dernière fois il y aura forcément des
incidents et où je l'espère cette fois
enfin ils seront soutenus en tout cas
les intentions du ministre sont plutôt
bonnes ça change des teriversations du
précédent ministre qui qui avait un
point de vue sur de la laïcité qui était
tout tout relatif je pense qu'il a fait
beaucoup de mal à l'éducation nationale
et je pense que ce dont on a besoin dans
l'éducation nationale c'est une vision à
long terme et qu'on arrête d'avoir des
ministre qui une fois blanquaire un
proit enfin très très attaché au ce
principe de laïicité papendia qui ne l'a
plus du tout et Atal qui redevient enfin
enfin allais je dire euh conscient des
enjeux donc moi j'ai une pensée pour les
enseignants et pour les difficultés
qu'ils vont avoir à faire respecter
cette minute de silence c'est bien beau
d'être au 20hur de TF1 en faisant des
des incantations et en expliquant qu'on
va on ne tolérera aucun aucun des
débordement mais ceux qui sont sur le
terrain ceux qui sont en face des élèves
ce sont les enseignants ce sont eux qui
souffrent et qui ne sont jusqu'à présent
absolument pas soutenus par leur
hiérarchie parce qu'on a peur parce
qu'on est faible et parce que on
naccepte pas qu'à un moment donné il
puisse y avoir des sanctions qui sont
des sanctions claires et fermes toujours
pas il y a toujours le règne du P parce
que Gabriel at il a dit hier qu'il
soutenait très clairement les enseignant
non mais là il y a un message qui est
clair le problème c'est que ceux qui
sont devant les enseignants ce sont les
professeurs devant les élèves ce sont
les professeurs pardon et que parfois et
moi je je connaisô très bien ce ce
milieul euh les enseignants ne sont pas
soutenus par leur hiérarchie quand il y
a des incidents parce qu'on a peur parce
qu'on est faible et combien de temps
est-ce que nous allons encore subir des
indignations des marches blanches des
des marches silencieuses avant d'ouvrir
les yeux et d'enfin réagir très très
clairement et très fermement
l'assaillant de d'aras il était suivi
par les services de renseignement ce qui
na pas empêché de commettre cet acte
est-ce qu'il y a une faillite des
renseignements généraux pour vous mais
je suis pas sûr que la faillite vienne
des renseignements généraux la preuve il
avait été reçu il avait été suivi euh le
problème c'est qu'il n'avait rien à
faire sur le territoire national le
problème c'est que quand
l'qtf l'obligation de quitter le
territoire français a été émise à son
rencontre elle devait être effectuée et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans une
situation comme les précédentes
d'ailleurs avec des gens qui n'ont rien
à faire sur le territoire national qui
sont des menaces pour la société qui
sont des menaces pour la France et qui
continuent en toute en toute liberté en
toute quiétude à jouir des droits que
les Français leur ctroi et et à nous
attaquer dès l'ors qu'ils en ont l'envie
mais lui il était pas expulable parce
qu'il est arrivé en France avant l'âge
de pris an est-ce qu'il faut changer ce
point il y a la loi immigration qui
arrive au Sénat dans moins d'un mois
est-ce que vous allez la durcir pour que
ce genre de de de fait ne soit plus
possible mais nous avons commencé à
travailler sur cette question et les ont
proposé des choses très claires et très
ferbl j'espère qu'aujourd'hui on sera
suivi j'ai beaucoup ri en attentendant
tout à l'heure François Ruffin nous
expliquit que cet individu n'avait rien
à faire sur le territoire national très
bien et bien qu'il vote la loi
immigration et qu'il la vote de manière
la plus sévère possible pour qu'on ait
les moyens de lutter contre ça
aujourd'hui il faut bien évidemment que
les jurisprudences des cours européennes
du Conseil constitutionnel en tout cas
arrête d'affaiblir l'action de l'État
puisque c'est ça qui au final nous
pénalise également il faut arrêter
d'être naïf et il faut enfin qu'on ait
une vision objective des choses les
islamistes sont en guerre contre nous
veut dire mais ça veut dire que vous
aussi vous êtes contint à un accord sur
cette loi immigration mais un accord
avec le avec le le dénominateur le plus
le plus le plus le plus dur possible et
ça vous paraît possible Gérald armanin
samedi il a dit qu'il fallait expulser
les étrangers Fichi pour
radicalisation écoutez je suis
entièrement d'accord avec lui je pense
qu'à un moment donné il faut prendre ses
responsabilités et arrêter d'être naïf
et arrêter de penser que tout va
s'arranger tout ne s'arrangera pas les
islamistes sont en guerre contre nous
contre notre mode de vie contre notre
liberté contre notre capacité à éduquer
nos enfants avec des valeurs qui sont
les valeurs de la liberté de l'égalité
de la fraternité et donc il est
nécessaire aujourd'hui de mettre un
terme à tout cela et arrêtons les
incantations en c'est bien de condamner
il faut le faire c'est bien de sofusquer
il faut le faire mais à un moment donné
qu'est-ce qu'on fait en face de tout ça
si nous nous continuons de cette
manière- làà je peux comprendre que nous
concitoyens commencent à avoir un
certain doute sur notre capacité à
mettre un terme à cette à cette cette
guerre qui est en train de se mettre en
œuvre chez nous sur notre territoire sur
notre sol contre nous est-ce que vous
faites un un lien entre la situation au
Proche Orient dont on va parler dans
quelques secondes et cette attaque à
haras écoutez je pense qu'on peut pas on
peut pas les les les dissocier je pense
qu'il y a des facteur déclenchant à C à
ce genre de à ce genre de de d'attaque
il y a beaucoup de choses il y a cont
Samuel pati a été assassiné parce qu'il
avait montré des caricatures là on a
affaire à un l'assassinat d'un
professeur d'histoire qui n'a rien fait
de particulier je n'excuse pas pour
autant l'affaire de de Samuel P un
professeur qui n'a rien fait de
particulier qui qui est visé parce qu'il
est professeur parce qu'il transmet
l'éducation parce qu'il transmet des
savoirs et donc évidemment il faut que
nous soyons le plus ferme possible sur
ce sujet Géral harmanin qui a annoncé
samedi que près de 200 actes antisémique
189 exactement avaient été commis sur le
territoire français depuis samedi
dernier depuis le début de l'attaque du
Hamas est-ce que c'est la preuve que
l'importation du conflit est bien là
mais ça veut rien dire le l'importation
du conflit ça voudrait dire que que que
qu'il n'y a aucun aucune aucun signe
avant courourur en France or ce n'est
pas le cas la situation elle est déjà là
vous savez ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
dans les collèges dans le territoire de
bfort il y a un collège un peu en zone
un peu sensible des enseignants me
racontaient que pendant les cours de
dans les pendant les récréations dans la
cour d'école les élèves se titillent en
disant tu es pour les juifs ou tu es
pour les Arabes voilà c'est ça
aujourd'hui la discussion elle est là et
et les enseignants font tout ce qu'ils
peuvent pour essayer de maintenir le le
le le couvercle sur la marmite qui est
en train de déborder et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce que ce dont ont besoin
les enseignants c'est d'un soutien très
clair et très ferme de leur hiérarchie
ne plus avoir peur de dénoncer des faits
de ne pas avoir peur de dénoncer des
actes ne pas avoir peur de transmettre
des savoirs au risque de pouvoir se
faire attaquer pour les les savoirs
qu'ils ont transmis je pense que le
soutien aux insignants est capital ils
en ont besoin on va parler de cette
guerre entre Israël et le Hamas alors
qu'une attaque terrestre de l'armée
israélienne semble imin on va faire le
point sur l'état des forces avec notre
journaliste Alex
[Musique]
poussa bonjour Alex bonjour Aran bjour
Cédric Perin bonjour et Alex l'armée
israélienne est l'une des plus
puissantes du monde oui tout d'abord
parce que ce pays investit beaucoup dans
sa défense en 2022 Israël a fait des
investissements militaires qui
s'élevaient à 23 milliards d'euros soit
4,5 % de son PIB un pourcentage qui est
deux fois supérieur au pays de l'Union
européenne et quand on détaille la
puissance militaire d'Israël il y a
d'abord les hommes avec des effectifs
importants 170000 soldats en activité
465000 réservistes mobilisables à tout
moment et d'ailleurs depuis l'attaque du
Hamas 350000 réservistes ont été appelés
pour avoir un un ordre d'idée la France
c'est aujourd'hui 200000 soldats et
43000 réserviste et puis le matériel
militaire est aussi une des forces de
l'armée israélienne qui dispose de 2500
chars de combat 5000 véhicules blindés
un réseau de défense antimmissile
performant avec le fameux dô de fer dans
les aires Israël détient 339 avions de
combat américains et sur mer six
sous-marins 14 navires de guerre et puis
en dernier recours israël possède
également des missiles des missiles
nucléaires même si officiellement ce
pays ne possède pas l'arme atomique
alors en face le Hamas et le hzbollah
Libanais également n'ont pas les mêmes
capacités mais ont développé leur
armement ah oui alors pour le Hamas rien
de comparable avec Israël mais
l'organisation terroriste s'est
constitué un arsenal patiemment ces
dernières années avec des armes venants
de Syrie de lib du Liban ou même de
Chine le Hamas est équipé de drones de
mines de missiles antichar de
lance-grenade d'obus de mortier 20000
hommes compos les brigades de ce
mouvement et puis du côté du hzbola au
sud du Liban euh le hzbola qui frappe
Israël par le nord et bien euh là le
hzbola est plus puissant il revendique
100000 combattants et dispose d'une
batterie de 200000 missile et face à
l'offensive israélienne le Hamas détient
les otages des otages dans la bande de
Gaza Alex oui ces otages captifs
seraient encore au nombre de 120 selon
l'armée israélienne parmi eux des
Israéliens des binationaux des étrangers
et également des femmes et des enfants
le défi pour l'armée israélienne et bien
c'est dans sa réposte d'épargner et de
récupérer ses otages et selon le Hamas
dans les bombardements israéliens sur
Gaza vendredi vendredi dernier qui ont
permis notamment d'éliminer l'un des
cadres du Hamas et bien ces
bombardements ont fait quand même ont
entraîné la mort de 22 otages Cédric
Perin pour vous l'offensive terrestre
israélienne elle est inéluctable
imminente écoutez ce qui est certain
c'est qu'elle est préparée euh
aujourd'hui toute la difficulté ça va
être de savoir qu'elle va-être
concrètement la réponse d'Israël à ces
attaques terroristes du Hamas parce
qu'elles vont conditionner
évidemment les conséquences d'un point
de vue internationale je pense
malheureusement qu'aujourd'hui euh la
guerre de l'opinion est en marche que
toute la politique toute la toutes la
les actions mises en œuvre pour le ramas
par le ramas depuis samedi dernier sont
des actions visant à radicaliser les
positions des uns et des autres pour
l'Occident ou contre l'Occident pour les
l'orent le Moyen-Orient ou contre le
Moyen-Orient et que évidemment toutes
les images qui sont diffusées ont pour
objectif soit d'énerver ou d'exciter la
population israélienne ce qui paraît
quand même complètement logique contte
tenu de ce qu'on a les atrocités qu'on a
malheureusement eu l'occasion de voir et
obligé finalement netaniao à une réponse
forte le problème c'est le respect du
droit international c'est le respect du
droit de la guerre et ce sont les
populations civiles et et donc et c'est
derrière tout ça la pays vous croyez pas
une réponse forte et juste comme le
demande Emmanuel Macron je pense qu'il
faut une réponse forte mais une réponse
juste et que peut-être que d'autres
moyens que que que que que des attaques
sur la population civile pourrait être
possible je ne sais pas je je je on
marche sur des ufs sur dans cette
situation c'est assez complexe mais en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
beaucoup regardent ou en tout cas si
leur plan vont être mis en œuvre et en
fait c'est un peu un jeu à qui per gagne
aujourd'hui naniiaahou est a soit une
possibilité de de réponse très très
forte au quel cas il se braque il se met
à dos l'opinion internationale l'opinion
publique internationale soit il réagit
un peu plus j'allais dire de manière un
peu plus circonstanciée et au quel cas
il se fait rattraper pour son extrême
droite et par une population israélienne
qui aujourd'hui y compris chez les plus
démocrates ou les plus euh j'allais dire
modéré euh attendre qu'il y ait une
frappe très très forte donc euh la
difficulté est là aujourd'hui ce sont
les populations civiles évidemment qui
qui vivent là et qui pour certains
d'entre eux je l'espère en tout cas ne
sont pas toutes pramass on voit aussi
qu'elles sont les exactions qui sont
subies par la population palestinienne
dans C dans ces bandesl est-ce qu'une
offensive terrestre dans la bande de
Gaza compromettrait selon vous le sort
des
otages écoutez il y a pas besoin d'être
grand clair pour imaginer que les otages
ont été mis en sécurité de manière très
disséminée dans des lieux très sécurisé
qui va être très très difficile aux
forces de sécurité de de de d'intervenir
pour les lib de manière enfin par la
force donc je j'ai pas de détails sur ce
sujets je ne m'aventurerai pas à en
parler de manière très très précise mais
il est bien évident que c'est quelque
chose de très complexe une autre
question Alex sur l'aide de Bruxelles
effectivement Bruxelles l'Union
européenne qui a annoncé et bien le
triplement de son aide humanitaire à
Gaza est-ce que vous vous approuvez nous
ce qu'on demande c'est le gel des aides
bilatérales et pas le gel des aides
humanitaires des aides humanitaires
elles ont pour vocation d'intervenir
auprès des popul tion pour les aider
dans à survivre j'allais dire puisque il
y a un blocus il y a il y a évidemment
des conditions de vie très difficiles et
donc ça ça ne me ça ne me choque pas
plus que ça en revanche ce qui est
absolument nécessaire c'est de mettre un
un un point très précis enfin une en
place une politique qui nous permette de
comprendre où va l'argent c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut arrêter donner de l'argent
pour financer des actes de terrorisme ou
des actes qui permettent une éducation
anti-occidentale anti-israélienne ça
c'est très clair quand on paye pour
financer des bouquins ou des livres dans
aux élèves pour expliquer que il faut
mettre à mort l'État d'Israël ou qu'il
faut attaquer l'Occident c'est bien
évidemment qu'on j'ai pas pour objectif
de payer lacorde avec laquelle on veut
me pendre la France appelle le Liban à
rester en dehors du conflit mais hier
Israël a frappé le Liban représaille à
des tirs est-ce que vous redoutez un
deuxième front avec le
hbola tout ça évidemment est à redouter
si on a on a vite compris samedi dernier
qu'il y avait pas une action coordonné
entre le hzbola et le Hamas puisque le
hzbola n' n'a envoyé que quel missile
que quelques missiles en terme de ou au
but en TI au titre de la solidarité si
je puux dire ça ainsi aujourd'hui la
question c'est l'Iran qu'est-ce que
l'Iran va va va va demander au au
hzbolah de faire ce que ce que que tout
le monde doit comprendre aujourd'hui et
je l'ai dit et je l'ai répété c'est que
l'Iran se bat avec la Russie à savoir
lequel des deux a inventer le jeu
d'échec l'Iran et la Russie jouent sur
un échiquet mondial et place leur pion
petit à petit les Palestiniens ne sont
qu'un pion dans le jeu de l'Iran et
l'Iran n'a que faire en fait des
Palestiniens mais c'est un pion qui
permet aux pales aux Iraniens d'avancer
leur tacti et leur jeux nous auourd'hui
juste qui Ava qui averti que nul ne peut
garantir le contrôle de la situation si
Israël envahit la bande bien sûr et nous
aujourd'hui nous jouons nous ne jouons
pas aux échecs sur un grand échiquet
nous nous jouons avec des pièces qu'on
place de manière aléatoire sans
réfléchir à quelles seront les
conséquences aujourd'hui l'Iran regarde
ça de très près et la question c'est de
savoir comment va réagir l'Iran alors il
y a une pression assez forte qui mise
vraisemblablement par les Américains sur
l'Iran pour les les contraindre en tout
cas à ne pas bouger mais nous sommes
dans un chaudron où tout peut arver AR
que doivent faire les Occidentaux donc
les Européens les Américains face à
l'Iran est-ce qu'ils doivent renforcer
leurs
sanctions écoutez je je je je pense que
ce que nous devons faire déjà c'est
essayer de tout mettre en œuvre pour
obtenir une déconliction de de de de
tout cela euh je pense que personne n'a
évidemment intérêt à à à ce que tout
cela s'embrasse ce serait évidemment
catastrophique euh les moyens sont sont
limités parce que je rappelle qu'il y a
quand même un certain nombre de fronts
aujourd'hui qui sont ouverts en Ukraine
en Arménie maintenant en Israël donc les
Américains ont déployé leur plus gros
porte-avion ainsi qu'un deuxième
porte-avion au au large d'Israël avec
une centaine d'avions et un message qui
est très clair donc il est bien évident
que nous devons surveiller ça de très
près et tout faire pour essayer de faire
comprendre à à l'Iran qu'il y a pas que
personne n'a intérêt à ce que les choses
s'embrassent quel quel rôle peut jouer
la France dans ce conflit Sébastien
lecnul ministre des Armées dit que la
France apporte du renseignement en
Israël est-ce que vous avez plus
d'informations moi j'ai pas plus
d'information que ça j'ai lu comme vous
l'article du Figaro qui dit que dans
l'interview de de de Sébastien lecnu on
apporte un certain nombre de moyens et
d'information le problème de la France
c'est qu'aujourd'hui elle ne parle plus
à personne le vrai problème il est là je
lisais un tweet de de George malbruno
qui disait le président de la République
samedi dernier le président de la
République a appelé mmoud Abbas que
qu'il voulait destituer 6 mois plutôt il
appelle le président du Liban qui n'a
plus de pouvoir en fait il n'a aucun
lien avec leur mass il n'a plus aucun
lien avec personne donc la France
parle plus Tunisie on parle plus on
parle plus à personne le vrai problème
c'est la diplomatie française qui a été
mise à mal par une politique de
réduction des coûts et par une politique
de de d'Emmanuel Macron qui s'est
considéré comme étant en gros le
porte-parole de l'Union européenne et
qui derrière tout ça c'est s pris la
porte dans la figure et qui aujourd'hui
est dans une situation où la France est
est j'allais dire discréditée or la
France a toujours été le pays dans le
monde qui parlait à tout le monde qui
avait cette chance de pouvoir dire
intervenir dans les conflits et et et
mettre en uvre une diplomatie
euh historiquement axée sur sur le
dialogue et sur la déconfliction
aujourd'hui c'est très compliqué est-ce
que vous allez prendre une initiative
ici au Sénat par rapport à ce conflit
nous allons nous allons faire voter une
résolution mercredi soir avec un certain
nombre j'allais dire de de de de
propositions mais qui sont des
propositions qui restent euh au niveau
de ce que peut faire un parlement
c'est-à-dire de la diplomatie
parlementaire qualifier les d'acte du
Hamas de de d'actes de terrorisme
demander la libération des otages
évidemment ça me semble la première des
choses demander on l'a dit le gel des
aides bilatérales et pas des aides
humanitaires et puis rappeler aussi le
droit d'Israël à se défendre dans un
conflit comme celui-là et puis et puis
également demander à ce que la
diplomatie se mette en œuvre pour
essayer de de de d'obtenir le le j' dire
la la d'éviter en tout cas l'embrasement
régional de du conflit mais ce sera une
résolution transpartisane je l'espère
mais vous en doutez non je pense pas
quand quand j'entends les propos de
certains élus de la France insoumise qui
ont eu des comportements absolument AB
ces derniers jours je me dis qu'on peut
arriver puis au Sénat on a quand même
des oppositions qui sont donc les élus
de gauche à vos C je l'imagine en tout
cas merci Alex à tout à l'heure on va
aller dans votre département grâce à nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
Belfort on retrouve Philipp bonjour
merci d'être avec nous directeur
départemental pour le Territoire de
Belfort à républicain Philippe vous
souhaitez revenir sur l'élection Cédric
Perin à la tête de la commission des
affaires étrangères oui bonjour merci de
m'avoir invité oui j'avais une
question qui était un petit peu le le
cadre de de cette commission des
affaires étrangères qui a une
particularité puisqu'elle agit sur un
domaine qui est le le seul domaine pour
lequel la Constitution donne des
pouvoirs propres au président de la
République on est dans le domaine
réservé du président de la République et
on a une commission parlementaire alors
comment et quel est le travail le rôle
d'une commission parlementaire dans dans
un domaine où la Constitution prévoit
que le président a des pouvoirs propres
bonjour Philippe euh des pouvoirs
propres oui évidemment mais pas
exorbitant non plus euh le le rôle de la
Commission c'est comme le nous nous le
l'ctroit à la constitution d'abord de
faire la loi mais surtout de contrôler
l'action du gouvernement or dans la
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement il
y a beaucoup de choses qu'on peut faire
euh et qui nécessite évidemment un
travail important en matière de contrôle
de de sur les sujets de défense
évidemment euh le contrôle j'allais dire
des de la manière dont le budget est
voté chaque année et surtout de la
manière dont il est mis en œuvre par le
gouvernement donc ça c'est quelque chose
auquel nous sommes très attachés et puis
nous avons aussi j'y crois beaucoup le
devoir et le président du Sénat il est
très attaché aussi de mettre en œuvre
une diplomatie parlementaire et à
l'heure où on parle de de grand grand
difficulté pour la France aujourd'hui à
parler à ses à ses voisins et à ses
anciens amis ou ses futurs ex amis la
diplomatie parlementaire doit jouer un
rôle important et on doit pouvoir se
dire entre entre élu re parlementaire
des choses que parfois les gouvernements
ne peuvent pas se dire et je le vois je
suis allé encore à
Copenhague pour l'ut temp la p autan le
weekend dernier on a eu des bilatérales
avec un certain nombre de pays qui nous
permett d'évoquer des points que nous ne
que peut-être les gouvernements ne
peuvent pas faire je pars à Berlin avec
une délégation de la S commommission de
la Défense le 6 le 6 novembre pardon
pour évoquer les sujets de coopération
industrielle en matière de défense le
SCAF le mgcs le drô de mal du futur et
cetera et ce sont évidemment des points
sur lesquels le Parlement doit pouvoir
accompagner le gouvernement et et et et
aider en tout cas à mettre en œuvre une
politique cohérente après sur les
pouvoirs exorbitants du président de la
République c'est évidemment la
constitution de la 5e République qui lui
donne qui cette Constitution a montré
combien dans des situations compliquées
ces pouvoirs étaient importants
maintenant il faut aussi que comprendre
que pour le président de la République
que le Parlement doit être associé doit
être concerté doit être consulté et
c'est sur une chose sur laquelle
l'ensemble des parlementaires se bat
Philippe vous avez une autre question
sur l'aspect défense cette fois-ci alors
oui une question qui en fait une double
question euh la première est une
question on va dire générale
c'est-à-dire que on a ces dernières
années travailler avec un cadre
intellectuel qui était celle d'une arme
de projection on l'a vu avec le Mali
avec avec d'autres pays et on se
retrouve avec une guerre classique je
dirais sur le sol du territoire européen
ce qu'on appelle des des guerres de
haute intensité qui ne demande pas du
tout les mêmes moyens en en homme en
organisation mais également en industrie
et on voit comment l'industrie de
l'armement est un élément extrêmement
important dans ce qui se passe en
Ukraine euh et donc je voulais connaître
votre position là-dessus et et deuxème
question juste un petit mot sur le sud
Liban on a parlé des bombardements sur
le sud Liban il existe depuis des années
la finule notamment on a dans le
Territoire de Belfort le premier
régiment d'artillerie qui est engagé
régulièrement dans les forces de l'UNU
dans cette région et est-ce que vous
pourriez nous faire un point de
situation de l'engagement des militaires
français actuellement sur le théâtre
d'opération entre le Liban la Palestine
et Israël merci alors le le le modèle
d'armée jusqu'à présent il a été
effectivement un modèle d'armée
expéditionnaire
euh qui jusque jusqu'à très récemment
est un modèle qui fonctionnait bien
puisquon était engagé sur des théâes
d'opération qu'on appelle asymétrique
c'est-à-dire
euh non non non ég entre les les
bellégérants et donc on était plutôt
dans une situation j'allais dire de
confort où ns matériels nous
permettaient d'avoir une une une
domination importante aujourd'hui on se
retrouve dans les conflits de ha
intensité effectivement de plus en plus
c'est le chef d'état-major qui est un
des lois de chez nous Thierry l' annoncé
maintenant depuis qu'il est arrivé et
anticipé et donc on doit aujourd'hui
obtenir les moyens de pouvoir se je dire
se défendre sur des théâtres d'opération
beaucoup plus équilibré de guerre d'état
à état et plus de groupes terroristes à
à à à état encore qu'aujourd'hui le
conflit israëlpalestinien montre que on
est sur un conflit asymétrique avec des
méthodes beaucoup plus modernes et
beaucoup plus j'allis dire développé
pour le Hamas que ce que ça été le cas
jusqu'à présent et donc il faut qu'on
qu'on évidemment qu'on tout ca mais ce
que je pense qu'il faut qu'on n'oublie
pas surtout en Europe c'est que la
France est un pays doté et le France
étant un pays doté de l'arme de de de
dissuasion l'arme nucléaire ça change
aussi considérablement la donne parce
que ça nous protège en quelque sorte
d'un certain nombre de de de de de
problèmes qui pourrai survenir mais pour
autant il ne faut pas tout miser
là-dessus et j'avais eu l'occasion de
dire d'ailleurs dans au moment du vote
de la loi de programmation militaire que
la dissuasion nucléaire ne devait pas
non plus devenir la ligne magino euh
française et qu'il fallait aussi
anticiper un certain nombre de choses
mais tout cela ça tourne autour de la
guerre de haute intensité la guerre
deute intensité et c'est c'est pas moi
qui le dit mais le chef d'État maajor
qui l'a défini ainsi il dit il faut la
guerre d'ité c'est la capacité qu'on
peut avoir au départ de de de de gagner
la guerre avant la guerre gagner la
guerre avant la guerre c'est gagner la
guerre de l'informationnel c'est ce qui
se joue en ce moment la guerre du
numérique la guerre du cyber ce sont des
guerres qui ont déjà commencé depuis
longtemps et si effectivement ces
guerresl ne sont pas j'allais dire gagné
et ben ensuite on rentre effectivement
dans une guerre d'intensité qui
nécessite de la masse du volume et des
capacités technologiques et et très
développé mais évidemment nous n'en
sommes pas là merci philiip merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous on
regarde la Une de l'Est Républicain
c'est le rugby une cruelle défaite pour
les Bleus c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci philippio un mot Cédric
Perin vous qui êtes fan de rugby sur
cette une é j'étais au match hier soir
comme tout le monde désespéré d'avoir
perdu un point je pense que voilà les
erreurs de la première mi-temps ont été
payé casche en deè un dernier mot sur
une autre actualité Cédric Perin on l'a
dit l'actualité est nombreuse en Pologne
l'opposition centriste pro-européenne a
remporté les législatives elle a battu
les populistes nationalistes et
l'extrême droite c'est un tournant
positif pour l'Union européenne
notamment dans la guerre en Ukraine un
tournant positif je ne sais pas en tout
cas c'est une bonne nouvelle et surtout
ça montre que euh on peut arriver aussi
à se défaire de l'extrême droite une
fois qu'elle é élu et il y a un certain
nombre de pays aujourd'hui dans en
Europe notamment qui sont poussés vers
cela mais ils sont poussés pars cela
vers cela par des paystiers comme la
Russie qui évidemment mettent en œuvre
en Afrique notamment des politiques
migratoires qui ont pour objectif de
déstabiliser nos démocraties donc je
crois que ce qu'il faut ce qui est
important c'est que nos concitoyens
comprennent qu'il y a derrière tout cela
beaucoup de manipulation et de lutte
informationnelle pour pousser les nos
concitoyens à se à se tourner vers des
partis politiques d'extrême qui soit de
gauche ou de droite d'ailleurs et qui
n'ont pour objectif que de faire du
populisme merci Cédric Perin merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demiheure